I wanna uh
present a petition today signed by Canadians across the country.
Uh, these things are concerned about the
nearly hundred thousand preborn children who die every year
uh since the mortgage mortgage decision.
Canada is only one of two uh nations in the world that has zero uh
laws protecting the preborn.
Uh they
they also note that uh Charles heartbeat begins when the child is uh
6 weeks old and they are calling on the government of Canada
and this place
to strengthen the protections for the preborn in Canada.
Thank you Mister Speaker.
When someone shows you who they are,
believe them. The federal conservatives have attempted for many years
to open up a debate on abortion in Canada
by sneaking in legislation or motions
or like the petition from yesterday.
Abortion is healthcare. It's as simple as that.
We don't legislate prostate exams or erectile dysfunction treatment
or breast exams
or MRI's or any other healthcare procedures because it's healthcare.
So don't get LED into a false sense of security about abortion access
here in Canada.
The federal conservatives are trying everything they can
to legislate our healthcare
and they've been attempting to do so for years.
So now is not the time to be complacent or to let our guard down
as I have said for many years
and as the federal conservatives have repeatedly shown us
given the chance
will attempt to limit access to abortion
or attempt an outright ban on abortion.
In Canada. So every opportunity that you have,
call out the conservatives and use your voice when it's time to vote.